what are your favorite movies ever
damn if I had to name a couple bro
definitely do some on boy we got like
Halloween
Napoleon Dynamite which Halloween though
because there's so many I mean we watch
all of them all of them because the last
one was [ __ ] we just be watching
Halloween ends was god-awful
it was but I I like watching Michael
Myers beat Michael Myers song right but
that movie was bad but like that [ __ ] do
you remember the one with Busta Rhymes
in it yeah that was funny they got that
[ __ ] and then they got like all the
off-brands the Rob Zombie one well you
remember the Rob Zombie Halloween them
was different yeah yeah them was good
that's his favorite [ __ ] he loved Rob
Zombie yo I [ __ ] House of a Thousand
Corpses what my [ __ ] that's his favorite
that was rejects one of my favorite
[ __ ] movies ever yeah that last scene
in Devil's Rejects where the [ __ ]
um what's the [ __ ] uh Leonard Skinner
it's playing free bird and they're
[ __ ] shooting at the top of the car
yeah I would be good
that [ __ ] is amazing that's hard and you
only see those [ __ ] actors in Rob
Zombie's movies because one of the dudes
well first of all the [ __ ] is his wife
yeah the lovely young lady is his wife
the queen is his wife and then the other
dude died the [ __ ] clown dude's dead
rest in peace and then the other white
dude is just I don't know
but they're only in his movies and
they're [ __ ] Devil's Rejects is the
[ __ ] yeah those movies are [ __ ] sick
so you got uh Halloween and Napoleon
Dynamite's a classic yeah I love that
then uh what else uh Brad just been
watching hella [ __ ] but if I had to put
it into categories because I can't
really name I like like horror movies
and like Thrillers and [ __ ] yeah and
like I don't know if it's not aware
movie right there I like just like
normal like I don't know what to call
like white people what's a white people
movie
is Napoleon Dynamite not a white people
movie is that a white people give me
another example I just want to see how
far we can go down this rabbit with what
a white person movie is
Napoleon Dynamite then you got uh like
[ __ ] I don't know this is so random
but like Meet the Fockers and [ __ ] like
give him his like white people movies
yeah but anything with Ben Stiller Ben
Stiller Will Ferrell that's that's why
people stuff 100 but it's hilarious I
mean Will Ferrell I mean look Adam
McCain I'm not Step Brothers but I'm
splitting Have You Ever Seen The Big
Lebowski yeah my favorite movie ever
look at this favorite movie yeah that's
just five That's a classic it's a great
movie yeah great [ __ ] movie